The Riddler always pushes Batman to his mental
limits, and it's no different in "The Batman."
Batman's foe leaves cards for him to find,
but there is more to them than initially meets
the eye.
Keep watching to learn why the Riddler's cards
mean more than you think.
The Riddler has never been more of an enigmatic
figure than in "The Batman."
While previous live-action iterations have
seen the character as a bit of a jokester,
particularly when it comes to Jim Carrey's
take on the character in "Batman Forever,"
he's deadly serious in this one, taking on
the aesthetic of a zodiac-type serial killer
in Gotham.
To make that real-world connection all the
more apparent, Riddler leaves behind puzzles
and ciphers at the scenes of his crimes for
Batman and Gotham P.D. to solve.
He's cryptic, all the way down to his capture.
That's the point where the cops realize he
has two separate I.D.
cards on him.
However, Riddler may be even slyer than most
viewers initially gave him credit for.
As it turns out, he hid secret Batman references
throughout many of the film's scenes in plain
sight.
But you have to be a real Batman aficionado
to catch all of them.
It becomes a recurring motif throughout "The
Batman" that Riddler leaves a card behind
for the titular vigilante at each crime scene.
The cards hold significance to the plot by
typically containing a riddle for Batman to
solve.
"Haven't a clue.
Let's play a game, just me and you."
But the cards themselves make for fun Easter
eggs all on their own for eagle-eyed fans.
Each card connects to a different Batman villain.
Perhaps the best-known example of this is
with the first card containing an owl featured
in "The Batman" trailer.
Many fans quickly pointed out the connection
to the Court of Owls storyline, with many
believing the arc could factor into the sequel's
plot.
It's unknown if that will be the case, but
it nonetheless makes for a fun addition.
Similar Easter eggs can be found with the
remaining four cards, as each one connects
with a different Batman villain.
The second card contains an image of a mad
scientist who bears a striking resemblance
to Hugo Strange.
The third card features a picture of a woman
dressed in green, which immediately makes
one think of Poison Ivy.
The fourth card is where things get tricky.
It's just a black background with two large
eyes looking toward the viewer.
It's reminiscent of the Cheshire Cat in "Alice
in Wonderland," and of course, Batman has
a villain who goes by the name of Mad Hatter.
Last but not least, the fifth and final card
has a boy with a puppet.
Fans of "Batman: The Animated Series" will
likely recall The Ventriloquist and Scarface,
a man and puppet duo who commit various crimes
in Gotham.
Any of these villains would make fun additions
to "The Batman" mythos, but for now, they're
relegated to references.
Batman has some of the most iconic adversaries
out of any villain out there.
No doubt this is helped in part from the litany
of Batman projects that have materialized
over the years, giving fans a glimpse into
the likes of Scarecrow, Penguin, and more.
While the cards hinting at other villains
within Batman lore would be enough for most
filmmakers, there are additional, stronger
hints that some of Batman's foes are out there,
just waiting to make a grand entrance in "The
Batman 2" and beyond.
The most obvious reference to this is when
Riddler is locked away toward the end of the
film.
He's naturally bummed that his plans went
into the sewer, and he could use some cheering
up.
That's where his cellmate next door comes
in handy.
While this individual never receives a name,
anyone who's seen a Batman property before
can surmise it's Joker by his signature laugh
and reference to clowns.
"You can call me Joker."
That's not the only potential reference found
in the film.
As Batman fights Riddler's minions, he finds
himself between a rock and a hard place.
He's beaten and worn down, but it's Catwoman
who is at the mercy of one of their foes.
To give himself a quick burst of energy, Batman
reaches for a vial containing a green liquid.
He then injects himself with the material,
and suddenly, he's on his feet once again
and beating the bad guys.
Given the enhanced strength and brutality
he displayed, it seems the substance is awfully
similar to the Venom Bane has used throughout
his run as one of Batman's villains.
Could this mean we'll get Joker and Bane in
one movie in the future?
One can only hope.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.